alors ça fait combien de temps que tu
est redevenu othman pas longtemps c'est
arrivé sans prévenir
j'aimerais pouvoir me battre contre les
méchants comme toi tu fais oui sauf
qu'avec moi sa fille nina près comment à
chaque fois
peut-être qu'il faudrait quelqu'un pour
t'aider salue un coéquipier
le père pim j'ai appris ce qui vous
était arrivé vous avez ouvert le portail
quantique et là ya cette espèce de singe
et de fantômes flippant qui traverse les
murs qui a déboulé qui vous appliquez
votre matos
et elle s'en servir pour dominer le
monde je sais pas quoi si c'est pas
dingue ça qui aurait imaginé qu'un jour
vous feriez apple n sûrement pas moi
parce que le cambriolage chez vous
c'était nous si on veut avoir une chance
on aura besoin de vous deux
en mode et la guêpe sa ses équipes
chez moi
[Musique]
elle semble plutôt efficace
en france
[Musique]
j'attaque par le au toit par le bas j'ai
les ailes pourquoi celle en bas
poliment par ippon on est papa
qu'est-ce que j'ai loupé ont été touchés
[Musique]
ok moi et tu auras sociaux sur un projet
intitulé colis à votre taille maxi
c'était quoi mon record je suis monté à
6 mai au 19 m 19 m ça y est vous avez
fini de vous comparer la taille 19
[Musique]